quel est le compliment qui vous énerve
le plus
vous avez une mémoire phénoménale si on
dit toujours mais comment ils font pour
apprendre tout ça quelle mémoire quelle
mémoire
salut ça va d'abord la même couleur de
cheveux qui est manuel et c'est raté
pour un film et je lui dis tu me fais
une couleur un peu blond PTT
comment ça va ça va bien j'ai utilisé
mon bonus
il y a pas très longtemps pour le film
de nicloo alors vous êtes actrice
scénariste auteur dramatique
réalisatrice et maintenant romancière
Josiane Balasko vous publiez votre
premier roman chez Fayard ça s'appelle
cliente et comme avec gazon maudit vous
abordez un sujet tabou décidément vous
êtes spécialisé un sujet encore plus
tabou apparemment oui
très très tabou et on peut pas le dire
[Musique]
le sujet tabou c'est les femmes
ont-elles droit au plaisir sans passer
par l'affectif en gros c'est ça en
payant donc voilà
oui pourquoi pas
pour les mecs
puisque j'ai moi au départ c'était une
histoire que j'aurais raconté en film
mais et finalement on m'a dit non faut
pas faire ça c'est dégueulasse c'est
dégueulasse histoire d'une femme de 50
ans passée qui se paye un mec 25 c'est
dégueulasse surtout pour de l'argent
sans même sentiment sans rien c'est
vraiment fou c'est immonde c'est marrant
c'est vrai c'est la limite aujourd'hui
de la l'acceptation de la société non
non c'est sérieux
parce que des histoires de clients qui
tombent amoureux de [ __ ] ça existe
depuis l'Antiquité
alors l'histoire on va parler de
l'histoire on s'est Judith qui est
cinquantenaire qui est patronne est
présentatrice d'une émission de télé
achats qui est divorcé qui est très
précis dans la vie elle a beaucoup de
choses à faire alors elle loue
régulièrement les services d'escort boys
comme on dit comme on dit poliment pour
satisfaire ses besoins sexuels voilà
tout simplement voilà pour vous aider
et un jour elle tombe sur un dénommé
Marco qui pratiquent en amateur et en
douce pour rembourser les trades du
salon de coiffure de sa femme c'est un
mec qui adore sa femme il s'aime
beaucoup et par amour il va se
prostituer alors contrairement aux
autres celui-là ce Marco alias Patrick
Judith va le voir plusieurs fois
jusqu'au jour où la femme de Marco
Patrick s'aperçoit de des activités
parallèles de son mari il lui promet de
s'arrêter mais comme elle a toujours des
problèmes avec son salon de coiffure
c'est elle qui lui demande de
recommencer
et puis les choses étant ce qu'elles
sont en situation économique et tant ce
qu'elle est les fins de mois sont
difficiles et la petite famille va en
arriver à redemander à son mari de
retourner au tapin quoi alors je vais
lire un petit je vous dérange pas que je
vais lire la
première fois
oui c'est bien
non non mais c'est bien parce que
le ton
[Applaudissements]
c'est incroyable mais je croyais que le
temps y est tu lis tu lis voilà j'ai lu
une émission littéraire c'est très drôle
ce principe bien alors la première fois
de Marco Patrick la première c'était sur
un chantier avec toutoune c'était la
proprio elle avait la quarantaine
frétillante on sentait qu'elle en
voulait toujours à plaisanter mes
classes et puis toutoune a commencé un
autre chantier j'ai fini celui-là tout
seul elle est devenue plus précise elle
me faisait du café elle venait de plus
en plus tôt elle était pas mal un peu
forte avec une grande bouche prête à
rigoler c'était au moment où Fanny
déprimé le salon avait ouvert depuis 6
mois ça démarre pas c'était limite on
lâche tout et puis après bon voilà elle
m'a pris dans ses bras elle était plus
grande que moi elle m'a serré contre
elle je me suis laissé faire c'est
confortable je me suis mis à bander sans
effort c'est elle qui m'a fait l'amour
après elle m'a donné de l'argent c'était
pas le tarif que je demande maintenant
mais c'était correct elle s'appelait
Liliane ça c'est la première fois donc
la première fois
poussé par le besoin parce qu'il est
très déprimé et la patronne du de
l'appartement dit mais qu'est-ce qui se
passe en gros c'est ça il lui explique
qu'il est très déprimé dit bon peut-être
faire un échange de service
et alors après donc Judith le rencontre
et elle dit je l'ai rappelé le lendemain
j'avais une trouille bleue en allant au
rendez-vous avec des idées du genre et
si c'était un pervers ou un sérieux le
killer les sérieux qui leur ont souvent
l'air très gentil quand on les voit à la
télé ils peuvent être jeunes et beaux
effectivement c'était un sérieux killer
plutôt un sérieux killer il m'a tué
plusieurs fois de suite une libération
comme lorsqu'on vous débloque un maire
j'ai joui honteusement j'ai rattrapé des
années de manque cet après-midi là tout
fonctionné la machine tournait impec pas
une toile d'araignée aucune sécheresse
dans l'orgasme j'imagine que pour un
type qui se remet aborder après des
années de flanelle ça doit être de même
un sentiment de détente d'apaisement le
monde autour de vous vous paraît moins
con et l'on se sent beaucoup plus
indulgent
très bien écrit
et là aussi c'est très cru on parlait
tout à l'heure de la crudité des propos
dire les mots comme ça c'était
ce que je vais dans le film c'est
difficile de dire les choses
[Rires]
le désir féminin donc qui est
parfaitement parfaitement
autobiographique je crois qu'on peut le
dire
j'ai commencé même une toute petite mais
12 ans il en avait cinq voilà
non en tous les cas bon vous vous dites
quand on vous en parle vous dites moi
j'ai eu la chance de retrouver quelqu'un
c'est une expression formidable
retrouvez quelqu'un c'est une expression
qu'on entendait quand on était petit ça
elle a retrouvé quelqu'un c'est pas une
an pour une femme de trouver odeur
trouver un homme parce que en général
son ex est barré pour une fille plus
jeune alors les types qu'elle a draguer
c'est quoi des mecs de son âge qui sont
pas intéressés ou quand ils sont
intéressants souvent ils sont déjà
mariés où ils sont [ __ ] mec sympa bon
vous ça va Josiane de ce côté-là vous
moi j'ai retrouvé quelqu'un
selon cette expression formidable alors
ceci étant vous avez plein de copines de
50 ans qui
qui sont sales et qui ont peut-être pour
avoir des copines de 50 ans qui sont
seules
et c'est un contenu comme ça je dirais
pas de nom par exemple
[Rires]
non mais elles ont recours à des à ce
genre de alors ça j'ai jamais rencontré
de clientes peut-être que j'en ai
rencontré mais je savais pas que ça
n'était sans doute on faisait partie
Emmanuel ça vous semble ça existe
j'aurais dû t'appeler quand j'écrivais
pour avoir des tuyaux parce que moi je
connais les sites internet mais je
connais pas ça existe je connais pas
dans Paris effectivement où les femmes
peuvent
pas précisément l'adresse mais l'endroit
d'accord c'est pas assez clair on me dit
on comprend qu'est-ce qu'ils disent les
spectateurs veulent plus de détails ils
sont sur les nerfs ils ont l'habite à la
main ils veulent et ici il va le
fabriquer les images ils s'entendent
tout le monde alors non mais c'est vrai
que 30 ans après la révolution sexuelle
quand même ça fait un moment que c'est
arrivé l'amour tarifait dans ce sens-là
ce choc toujours les gens mais c'est pas
je crois que c'est pas c'est le fait que
d'un seul coup la femme prenne
possession prenne le contrôle de son
plaisir
donc ça c'est dégueulasse quand même
alors là vous êtes pas arrivés à monter
le film mais vous êtes devenu écrivain
malgré vous c'est plutôt bien
et donc maintenant vous entrez dans le
monde des lettres
Bernard Pivot je sais pas il faut oui je
sais pas
alors maintenant vous êtes écrivain vous
allez dire que le cinéma a tué la
littérature
je raconte des histoires alors si je
peux pas les raconter d'une manière on
peut les raconter d'une autre voilà
c'est ça
[Musique]
vous allez dire que c'est vulgaire de
faire rire non bon je vais essayer de
faire rire en écrivant on dira peut-être
que c'est vulgaire
c'est bien réussi
pour trouver une inspiration
12 litres par jour c'est trop bien
[Rires]
donc si tu veux c'est vrai que c'était
les cigarettes
comme ça un beau triangle
maintenant que j'ai écrivain vous rêvez
d'écrire pour le cinéma j'imagine comme
tous les écrivains
[Musique]
alors le livre peut devenir un film ou
jamais de toute façon c'est pas c'est
pas très grave il existe peut-être c'est
une possibilité comme pour tout bouquin
voilà alors on va vérifier quand même si
ce scénario en tous les cas avait les
ingrédients d'un film qui fasse des
entrées est-ce qu'il y a une happy Yann
c'est pas une fin totalement malheureuse
voilà mais c'est pas non plus c'est
comme dans la vie quoi
qui se calme à la fin non merde est-ce
qu'il y a des effets spéciaux
pratiquement pas il y a pas non plus de
bagarres en karaté il y a plus de
bagarres Hong Kong
fou là est-ce qu'il y a un rôle pour
Depardieu
non ça c'est emmerdant est-ce qu'il y a
un petit garçon qui découvre par hasard
grâce à un hibou qui les magiciens
[Rires]
mais pourquoi j'ai pas pensé plutôt toi
la seule chose
donc Josiane Balasko c'est chez Faya et
je vous le conseille voilà sur le plan
sentimental tout va bien mais écoutez
tout va bien vous êtes prêtes à beaucoup
de choses par amour non
oui déjà du vivre avec un homme c'est
être prête à beaucoup de choses et plein
d'autres trucs
[Applaudissements]
interview par amour est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prêt à vous déguiser en
Elton John alors bien sûr c'est pas si
compliqué j'ai déjà la couleur de
cheveux est-ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à cacher quelqu'un qui vient de
tuer
c'est possible c'est possible ouais ça
pourrait faire un bon début de
l'histoire de son arbre d'ailleurs c'est
possible oui bien sûr
non non
et apprendre 17 kg ça m'est arrivé
[Rires]
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prêts à
accepter quelques infidélités
c'est possible ah oui je comprends que
vous soyez
impossible salut
vous accepteriez qu'il ait une maîtresse
apparemment
ça dépend ce qu'on entend par Maîtresse
de temps en temps oui ça vous dérange
pas je sais pas peut-être que si c'était
de temps en temps souvent ça me
dérangerait puis ils sont des fois on
sait pas sachant qu'ils savent pas non
l'important c'est quand l'un des deux
trompes l'autre c'est que le reste du
temps ça se passe bien à la maison mais
souvent quand l'un des deux trompes
quand il revient il fait la gueule c'est
tout le problème
va se détendre et rentre à la maison
elle est plus heureuse et qu'elle rend
plus heureux ou qu'il rend plus heureux
ça ça suffisait heureux ça compagne
pourquoi pas mais si c'est pour faire la
gueule parce qu'il culpabilise car
j'aime tout sur l'autre comme ça arrive
très souvent non
vous seriez prête à vivre à trois avec
la maîtresse
[Rires]
ça je sais je crois pas que ça puisse
marcher je crois pas que ça puisse
marcher à long terme je parie que ça
veut dire des couples dans qui ça peut
marcher parce que c'est sous toujours le
mec qui est chef parce que le mec est
quand même polygame l'homme par une
polygame de nature la femme est
homonogame donc c'est emmerdant quoi
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
ne plus jamais faire l'amour
[Rires]
je regarde comme ça qu'on regarde tombe
sur toi sans aucune tension
malveillante est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à changer de sexe
c'est à dire que par exemple
découvrir de nouveaux territoires des
choses auxquelles ils ont jamais pensé
changer de sexe Josiane je rencontre un
homme me dit je t'aimerai tellement
mieux si tu étais un homme est-ce que
vous feriez greffer un pénis et ça
voudrait je voudrais pas entrer les
tests
est-ce qu'on a besoin de se le faire
greffer il y a des enseignements
[Musique]
alors tiens ah on va vous faire
l'interview que j'ai fait tout à l'heure
à Emmanuel Béart qui terrible attention
interview
upside down
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
deuxième Balasko quel défaut doit avoir
un homme pour vous séduire à part le
priapisme
s
quelle est l'insulte qui vous a fait le
plus plaisir
[Rires]
elle est phénomène allemand vulgaire
quel est le compte c'était quoi Emmanuel
les gens ne sont pas choqués par la
tenue mais par l'horaire c'est beaucoup
trop tôt
quel est le compliment qui vous énerve
le plus
vous avez une mémoire phénoménale si on
dit toujours mais comment ils font pour
apprendre tout ça calmer moi quelle
mémoire quand je vais voir des comédiens
sur scène au théâtre je leur dis mais
comment vous faites pour apprendre tout
ça parce que
je sais qu'est-ce que vous voudriez que
vos enfants ratent leur bac
contraire de toi
[Rires]
que leur interdisez-vous à vos enfants
que vous ne vous interdisez pas quand tu
étais plus petit dire de vous grossier
moi j'avais le droit ou pas les pétards
aussi j'imagine non c'est difficile
enfin c'est difficile
mais pas toujours derrière parce qu'en
général si il fume ils viennent pas le
faire sous votre nez
pour quelles raisons seriez-vous capable
de refuser votre plus belle histoire
d'amour
pour des raisons fiscales
quel est le film à succès que vous êtes
content d'avoir refusé
de films
[Rires]
que je refuse que j'ai pas forcément
voir par exemple
tu m'as même pas tu m'as demandé mais
j'étais en train de bosser [ __ ] si pas
le problème de Laurent c'est qu'il
insiste pas à toi
je peux pas là il va pas il faut
insister dans ce métier si tu veux
réussir tu as essayé de coucher non non
si au début tu couchais quand même j'ai
arrêté toujours de dos c'est chiant on
voit pas les gens quoi il y a pas
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu